uh it also depends on magnus's opening
choice with black it's so hard to
freestyle and just kind of push your h
pawn out the board do something a bit
weird and wacky i think magnus respects
ding too much for that but also it would
backfire if he does get too brave ding
is just too too strong
to not punish magnus if he
is a bit flashy in the opening so
i think the first few moves of this game
will be very very exciting to watch and
okay ding starts with the english
opening yeah not his typical 1d4
remember ding with the candidates next
month he has to hide some of his
preparation he doesn't want to reveal
exactly what he's going to do in the
opening and
okay magnus plays g6 which is actually
quite a solid move um he's got a firm
idea behind it black's bishop wants to
go to the g7 square onto the long
diagonal and uh well now it may be not
so solid as in we could get a grimfield
or a king's indian defense and
the kings in the defense we were talking
about gwen's great course that he's done
for chesapeal on this opening and that
was the prize yesterday but this can
lead to extremely double-edged exciting
play not the way dings played it though
okay but this is okay but again maybe
he's saving his preparation here with
such a move yep it's clear that ding
doesn't want to tell his future
opponents next month in the candidates
exactly what he's going to do in the
opening
ding here has just chosen a very modest
very calm way of developing you see
white's bishop has just moved maybe not
to the most active square but the pawn
push in front of that white bishop
that's not regarded maybe as the most
challenging setup for white
it's still popular it's still kind of
geared towards getting a really rich
double-edged tense middle game but
this is not what ding normally does so
okay
now we will see magnus with a double
fianchetto both of black bishops on long
diagonals and
ding almost moving
i mean making the pieces levitate it
looks like he hasn't even flinched the
pieces uh just flying forward though
this is the power of the mind
the jedi force
what is quite curious about this uh
opening that ding has played is that it
doesn't look like it's the most
dangerous opening but checking out the
database i can see that
actually it's been pretty dangerous
players who've handled it with the white
side it's been a favor of mamajara of
nakamura fabiana caruana and
actually now they're into a game that
ding himself has played before this one
was in 2022 just now in the huang zhu
tournament
ding one in a big
long game david you'll be proud yeah i'd
be proud of the long games but um the
thing is white's not necessarily going
for a winning advantage any time soon
while it's not playing for the attack
white's just trying to steer the game
into
kind of a really tense position notice
how all the pawns all the pieces are on
the board and it's likely to stay that
way for a while i mean while ding with
this last bomb push trying to gain as
much space as possible and magnus
challenging the white pawns i'm
surprised by this one i think that white
pawn that is now under fire from black's
a pawn is just going to push up the
board there we go
and white has gained a lot of space now
um
magnus meanwhile just pushing upon
getting ready to develop that black
knight that black knight that's sitting
at home needs a square to go to it's a
bit dominated right now and here we go
ding does indeed develop yeah this one
is going to be a
real uh maneuvering game for the next
few moves aha i agree and both um i
don't think we're in known territory at
the minute okay there's just been two
games but uh we've deven ding has
deviated from his earlier game in 2000
2022.
and uh actually quite liking this for
whites you know
fishing pawns yes taking space it's my
favorite thing it's a very solid
position for black though i mean it just
kind of resembles a lot of positions you
can get from the nimso indian and
openings like that and
but in those openings you don't have
this bishop in front of the king which
black has here black has this double fee
and chateau structure
and you know i i don't think magnus
would be too unhappy here at least
because he's just he's got no weaknesses
he's got a lack of space but he's got
nothing obvious to attack but of course
white is a little bit easier to play
because yeah he's got more space and
having more space means easier game and
i think it's just about coming up with
plans here we will see the players slow
down because here white would love to
for example push even further forward
gain even more space create this
beautiful pawn center but i'm not sure
he should rush because suddenly black
would just block up the center suddenly
there's a bit of tension between these
two pawns if white continues doing what
he would normally do for example push
forward then suddenly this side of the
board the queen side is just completely
locked down look at all these pawns
they've just completely blocked each
other up and actually in this type of
position it's normally black who attacks
on the right half of the board so this
would favor magnus for example the black
knight would come to the side at some
point black would start pushing forward
this is actually transposing towards the
king's indian it's like a
mishmash of all these different types of
openings simon mentioned the nimzo it's
got uh qualities of the nimzo indian
it's got qualities of the kings indian
it's got qualities of the hippo defense
it's uh like everything just thrown
together in a hybrid so these players
they know it's chessable monsters they
know we're talking about openings
yeah and uh they're definitely just
using all the patterns they recognize
from all these different openings trying
to put them together and that's why ding
i think has hesitated he doesn't
necessarily want to rush pushing pawns
forward because then it makes things
easier for black
yeah so i'm expecting white's bishop the
dark square bishop that hasn't moved
maybe just to vacate the first rank when
in doubt just connect your rooks bring
the rooks towards the center and then
you'll be ready for the action okay i
guess you just got to decide where that
bishop goes uh when you're playing with
white hair i mean it's a normal thing to
think about you want to put your pieces
when you're bringing them out the best
squares possible i'd be tempted to go
like a4
use that pawn two squares fours maybe
you could show that and maybe even put
the bishop on this square but i wanted
to have my pawn in front of that
uh that one but maybe saving that for
the night normal maneuver's still going
on david and yeah is is magnus going to
push in the center with that pawn move
at some point maybe anyway yeah i think
both sides now are ready um after this
last couple of root moves now white's
rook opposite the black queen it means
that black won't be comfortable if the
position opens and as simon mentioned
magnus here would love to for example
push forward his central pawn but he has
to calculate suddenly white has the
option of pushing his pawn forward and
suddenly it's chaos this pawn's looking
at this one this pawn's looking at this
one but white is the one with threats
pushing forward now to attack two pieces
at the same time and the reason i'm
thinking this requires calculation is
for example if that captures this pawn
white would be happy to recapture
suddenly remember this rook looking down
at the black queen um i think this one's
going to turn out quite well for white
after another capture for example
white's bishop i think that's better
move even but white's bishop for example
could take this pawn utilizing the fact
that this black knight is pinned black's
knight cannot go and capture the bishop
because the black queen would drop
behind it so already
it looks like a really quiet position if
we retreat if we kind of rewind back to
the position that magnus is thinking
about but things will burst into life
just in the case of one move for example
if ding gets the opportunity to push
this pawn suddenly it's going to become
really really double-edged wow so i
think the critical moment is
maybe even now or in the next couple of
moves wow how cool and it's a critical
moment in the tournament for so many
players so we are keeping an eye on many
of the games going on here in round 13
especially be dit arianthari they are
right outside top eight
and those who are fighting to qualify
penta hare krishna is the player in
eighth place now playing against jordan
fan for east and pragnanda he is in
seventh and now playing the youngest
player in the tournament mishra the
old against the 16 year old paying
attention to that one as well
but this one between magnus he is in
second and uh ding
only one point behind magnus they will
qualify for the knockout stage but it's
always important to be as high on the
table as you possibly can
yeah and they both look really focused
to be honest they both i mean they're
basically mirroring each other's body
language a moment ago both of them just
covering their faces and
maybe ding is one of the players i know
magnus has probably said only ali raza
faruja is the person he will play but
i'm kind of thinking like ding might be
another one that if ding does win the
candidates i think magnus be like yeah
this guy this guy's a good rival i might
play so i'm kind of like you know he
kind of wants to play these top players
and you can sort of see that here can't
you i mean he's really dedicated even
when there's uh big football games going
on elsewhere you know which he loves his
football they've got the exact same hand
gesture over their faces right now
and they're just mirroring each other
changing it up there but yeah yeah i
mean
seconds on chest psychology goes yeah
can they see each other i i don't think
they can can they they can't they can't
oh right they can opt to but they can
opt to kind of minimize the webcam as
well normally i don't think magnus looks
at his opponents unless he's kind of
checking in on them at a critical moment
or uh
so this is what you've got to do to uh
to become a strong player just copy
their face with their hands you're
basically saying that you're
so okay now there are two hands in front
of the face will magnets do the same
good question it's 10 isn't it i mean
you don't normally see magnus this this
tense in in a game of chess when he's
playing online
well we can see he's now pushed out in
the middle but it's kind of like you
were saying david it doesn't seem like
there's a lot going on it's kind of like
i don't know i guess you could call it
an iceberg position because it's like
you can see the top of the iceberg but
there's so much there's a massive
iceberg below the water with all the
pieces just ready uh to come to life but
i like magnus's last move and if i was
black here i would love to push that
pawn one square forwards and do a
typical attack that actually bobby
fischer made
very popular in these types of positions
uh and if you've got bobby fisher's book
my 60 memorable games he's he's got a
couple of victories where he plays this
kind of uh this kind of idea and yeah
david maybe shows the show for example
if white just plays a quiet move if
black does establish this pawn in the
center of the board um i think it was
you simon you said this brought this
pawn cuts the board in half in a way and
now black can focus his attentions for
example starting to throw harry the h
pawn down the board i know magnus
wouldn't hesitate from this and uh look
at the white king it actually has very
few defenders around it um all of the
defenders for white now they're all on
the other flank they're all on the
opposite side of the board so that's
normally a signal to attack and as simon
mentioned
this has uh definite definite
similarities to other openings
especially the king's indian attack not
the king's indian defense it's when
white establishes a king's indian attack
and bobby fischer one of the
connoisseurs of that
i know magnus played that a lot in his
youth it's all about getting a pawn to
this square backing it up with all your
pieces note how many pieces defend this
black pawn is it four pieces and as long
as you can keep this pawn here then you
cut the board in half and you can go for
the white king also white's queen is
stuck on the wrong half of the board
here she can never kind of jump across
and save her king later on nor can the
white knights so a bit of a positional
threat um this move if magnus gets it i
think he's going to be very very happy
so can ding stop that that's the
question if he takes pawns off in the
center of the board then black will say
okay i'll trade i'll recapture with the
knight and if we see some exchanges
suddenly i like black again black's
bishop is phenomenal on this diagonal
and white's pawns are completely stuck
these pawns can never push forward
saying that though i mean if black does
push that pawn forwards it's kind of
position you don't often see magnus play
because he has to really go all in for
the king side attack i mean we know he's
very capable of doing that but he
doesn't tend to enjoy those
all-in attacking positions as much as
other people would when he was younger
he played those types just a little bit
but you're right he went away from them
he doesn't want to
um doesn't necessarily want to kind of
take too much risk like one thing i have
noticed is that the computer
will in those type of positions that you
highlighted with the black pawn being on
the e4 square the computer will actually
say white is much better
because the computer is such a great
defender but in terms of a human player
well it's a very scary attack to face
and the only way that white can meet it
oh and he's taking the pawn
uh i mean it just goes to show that he
was worried um i wonder whether he's now
going to just uh stick a knight into the
center of the board that's maybe what i
would do must be his idea mustn't it to
to to counter attack in the middle there
i guess
yeah yeah i don't think white should
rush to trade off pieces here because
um from all the pieces that come off the
board i think just black has no
weaknesses at all i don't think black's
going to be in any
well magnus is not going to be concerned
if all of the knights leave the board
for example so uh jovanka you mentioned
a knight coming into the center which
one there's a choice of two do you mean
this knight coming
to block black pieces in or do you mean
keeping these knights on the board not
trading instead dodging the trade
and uh this knight looks pretty good
yeah i must admit i only saw one night
and it wasn't the one going to the
fourth fourth row i only saw the knight
hopping into the middle of the board
yeah i would be
very hesitant i don't know um after the
black bishop takes after a recapture for
example if we do see a trade um at the
moment black does have this weakness
this backward pawn which can never move
otherwise it just gets captured but if
black can defend it somehow
i'm not sure exactly how but for example
just putting a rook on this square or
even temporarily this one if black can
now get a night round to this outpost i
don't think black's ever worked but he's
played it he's played at ding he's gone
in yeah he's gone in so we could be
headed towards a position like this one
um black's queen was under fire so the
knight had to be removed and exactly
what we just showed actually
all black needs to do i think to be okay
is to transfer his knight to this
outpost to block up
you need to block up and plug this open
file where your target is okay magnus
takes a step back with this queen the
reason you can't do this immediately
drop back with the knight is because
white's queen can suddenly take this
pawn it's undefended and that's why
black drops his queen back first
defending the pawn and now his plan next
move is to bring his knight back
um it's all about whether black's knight
can get around
uh-huh
yeah yeah there's some dangers isn't
there i mean like you could maybe showed
out on the ls analysis board a little
bit more that you know normally when
you're playing these positions as white
you want to exchange off uh the
fianchettoed bishop of your opponent so
let's say you go bishop back to b2 you
know this is kind of a normal idea get
rid of the bishop in front of my
opponent's king but now if the knight
goes back these pieces get exchanged i
mean that night after one more move
let's say white plays something look at
that knight and look at white's bishop
in this case white's bishop be very bad
but
when in doubt when it down what did you
do
maybe i mean why not you know i mean uh
i i get asked this quite a lot people
say when do you push the h pawn you know
when do you push it and the answer is
always no it's not
but magnus is trying to prove that but
it is when
normally your opponent has that
fianchetto structure so you've got a
target to attack so you can see that
pawn now coming up and it's kind of
attacking black's king side a little bit
it's a bit of a nuisance so this is this
is normally when you push the h pawn if
anyone's wondering i think in the past
uh the reason it wasn't such a popular
idea pushing the pawn up the board is
because often it would be linked with
for example a trade and then trying to
use the open line but that's not so
effective it takes a long long time for
the rook to kind of occupy the open h
line but the reason it's so popular
nowadays is because in a position like
this you actually leave it here as long
as possible and later if uh for example
you can get the pawn up to this square
and then you in an end game you cage in
the black king and they're all kinds of
mating ideas but meanwhile a few moves
on the board we have seen a queen trade
um if we just backtrack the what the
black queen came out and actually
offered this trade and after the queen
trade
i don't know i think black should just
be solid enough no real weaknesses in
the current position
ding also pushed his g pawn why did he
only push it one square not two to
support the h pawn yeah i think you're
right he might push it later um he
pushed this squat uh this pawn forward
while queens were on the board so maybe
he thought if the pawn went too squares
forward the white king would be a bit
open okay um so now that queens have
left just over the last couple of moves
maybe later we'll see the pawn continue
pushing
but meanwhile let's go back to the
players a lot of moves but we're almost
in the end game now and
i just don't really see a plan for white
other than pushing pawns black's knight
is just too strong at the moment
magnus has played super fast he still
has almost 14 minutes left on his clock
after 25 moves it is definitely ding
doing the thinking so far yeah i i
actually think that magnus is simply
satisfied with the draw and
doing something i did not expect
well david did mention this isn't he
this is like the modern way to play and
i it's i did this course recently for
chess ball it's called uh the the sort
of h-porn idea against the kings in
defense and one thing i found
really strange is that a lot of top
players are putting that pawn there uh
praganan uh is one of the players prague
he was doing this a lot as well and it's
just having those chances later on but
you know it does look quite equal here
doesn't it i mean you have to probably
exchange that night off at some point
and i say that and he's going for
another plan ding loves his bishops
i think i mean a lot of top players they
love their bishops especially when
they're on a pair ding loves it more
than anyone
and
yeah the reason i think we're both
surprised is that black's knight is just
too strong black's knight is on an
outpost can never ever get kicked away
by porn and it has a lot of influence
actually the black knight not only
blocking the white rooks but uh kind of
controlling some central squares
then again white's bishops if you can
somehow trade off the rooks maybe may
maybe then they'll come to life a bit
later this is the one plan isn't it a
white scott white can use his poor
majority and this is this is something
always worth looking at i mean white's
got more pawns on the king side than
black has so you can try pushing them at
some point and the only way i i think
that white's gonna be able to do
anything though is by pushing the e pawn
at some point i i don't see how he's
gonna manage to ever do that so uh but
possibly a bit easier for white to play
here definitely i mean black's a bit
stuck right so magnus just moving the
black king there um just to show your
your point there simon eventually uh
we're going to see a lot of maneuvering
now but eventually white's only winning
plan is to push this pawn forward but i
mean this square is covered four times
by black's pieces so somehow you need to
kind of move your bishop out the way
push the pawn next to it it just takes a
long time and you always have to worry
about this pawn in the center of the
board and this is just waiting magnus
he's obviously happy with the draw which
you would be here i mean so he's just
moving his king back uh here and then
he's moving it back and back again and
just waiting meanwhile we should point
out that magnus can't really take this
pawn it's defended sufficiently but
after a set of trades here suddenly it's
not about trading rooks it's about the
fact that blackstroke has left the
defense of this pawn
so suddenly white would take and it's
not just that but all of the pawns from
dark squares easy targets for white's
bishop
so that's why magnus is reduced to just
waiting with the black king so the
question is can ding improve it might
take a long long time maybe you can i
was about to say move the king out of
the way somewhere next move you step
your bishop back out or the for example
if magnus waits you would step he does
that and uh for example if magnus
continues to wait you need to find the
right moment to push this pawn forward
to support
a push in the center but do you think
magnus's work literally just going to
move the king backwards and forwards
because
that would be i don't think i've ever
seen that i know it's a good plan
because he's got his pieces to optional
squares but literally just moving the
king backwards and forwards while your
opponent can do whatever he wants is
strange right definition of a fortress
right you know just shuffling the king
just but uh you know it's it's actually
difficult to recommend doing anything
else
i mean you can't push a pawn no you
can't move your knight you can't move
your rooks yeah yeah yeah why not agree
yeah it's he's just got to wait
i mean that can't be too much fun just
sitting there seeing i'm hoping we're
going to see a hundred move game ding
just waits for 30 moves while magnus
brings his king back and forth and then
slowly pushes the pawn then wait another
30 40 moves push your pawn
this is a dream position for dink well
you know it would be a good learning
experience and whilst
the king is shuffling backwards and
forwards or sideways rather um well we
do have a quiz of the day where we're
asking what is your experience with
chassis ball chest was all about
learning and uh sunny doobie says that
my experience with chess ball has been
in a very committed relationship since
ages with closeness support mutual
understanding improvements and
acceptance of my strengths and
weaknesses oh what a great answer yeah
and uh vega taurus is very gives us a
very honest answer he says my experience
with chessable is to use the free stuff
especially simon williams courses
perfect
can you get your wallet out and buy some
my stuff i've got to feed myself
stop downloading the free stuff
come on
come on
if you want to enter our quiz of the day
then you can tweet us using the hashtag
champs yes for a chance to win a niche
gears course on uh the najdorf sicilian
great course valued at over 300 so a
great price today and the king well it
keeps going sideways yes and meanwhile
ding has actually repeated the position
once so this is actually um the second
time we've seen this position if we see
ding just drop the light squared bishop
back well the second time we've seen
this position as well okay ding is
playing for the win he's moving his king
back i'm not sure where that white king
is going but it's going somewhere
and uh meanwhile magnus does not care at
all he's just uh moving the black king
would you have some fun if you were ding
and just move your king like first of
all to the left move it to the right and
then you know fish a porn so just move
the white king to one corner and then
the other corner maybe you could break
that record right just 200 and david
would love this position so much
he would he would move every piece and
get to move 49 and then he had played
this
i can see david literally playing 49
moves because after 50 moves it's a draw
if you don't make a pawn move playing
this move waiting another 49 moves
playing a3 another 49 going a4 i could
just you know and magnus just moving the
king back to the forwards
i'm disappointed dink did push this pawn
as simon mentioned you could wait 49
moves push this one with 49 moves later
push this pawn 49 moves later push this
one 49 moves later push this one and uh
we'd easily get to move 300 but uh ding
actually has a specific idea in mind by
pushing this pawn forward he's protected
his stronghold in the center um this is
a nice pawn chain now and looks at
what's happened um after magnus moved
his king the white bishop has actually
found a great diagonal ah not sure what
it's doing it's hitting thin air but it
does control a lot of squares takes away
from those squares from black's pieces
so meanwhile magnus continues to wait
ding is continuing to play with his king
at some point remember he's going to
maybe move this bishop out the way um
maybe even now he's um in this position
he's going to move his bishop out the
way move the rook to the center somehow
support his pawns and start pushing
these guys forward takes a long long
time to arrange but he's got all the
time in the world on the board at least
on the clock he's down 10 minutes almost
but
here he's just moving the white king
back and forth to gain a few seconds
every turn i did wonder whether magnus
could get ambitious you know and say
well you know you did like you pushed
the f pawn and therefore maybe allow me
some opportunity to kind of break open
the center but okay this involves moving
the bishop out of the way
for example in the current position or
something like this and then trying to
push this pawn yeah open up the black
rooks threatened it
i mean i i i
would be very brave for magnus to do
this he's shown no indication of trying
to do and i'm trying to win this game i
think the problem with this is maybe the
bishop hits the rook and then you're
committed to
moving that pawn maybe at some point are
you i mean i guess you could move the
rook but
it's a little bit risky for example if
you push this pawn blocking your own
bishop in the corner um white can just
happily retreat at some point and yeah
this is a dead piece
so maybe possible but it comes with a
risk i think that's why magnus said no
more risk just a clear plan he can
almost breathe
he's direct and he has pre-moved the
next 50 moves
he's just gone to make himself a cup of
tea or something he's just literally you
know pre-move right 50 moves in a row
just go and have it you know
like yeah you can't do that there's some
danger though because they could we
could just be bishop takes night i
should take it yeah then everybody else
and i've seen david that happened to
david enough sitting next to him in in
bullet chess you know so uh yeah are you
going wrong well dingler and he is
fighting for the win and he is ready for
the candidates we've talked about that
camp dates will start mid-june and there
is a story on chess24.com
ding's thoughts on eventually making it
to the candidates
becoming world number two and playing
those 30 games that he had to play to
qualify and you can read that story
apparently he has booked his ticket to
madrid where the candidates will be
played
has magnus's camera frozen oh um a few
moments ago just before this uh just
before ding moved magnus had the exact
amount of time he started the game with
so on move 42 magnus still had over 15
minutes but maybe very soon yeah so cool
well he's he's gone for your prank
because you're back so oh
that was just uh
i wasn't really being that serious
well you're gonna have to go with it now
so
i mean
i i was actually thinking like i'm
probably not david but if it was me or
you ivanka yeah um and magnus was
playing black against us just because
david's a lot harder he's gone for it
he's gone
wow
why is this a whack because he could
have just moved the king backwards and
forwards but you know this is uh magnus
saying hey i'm going to take risks he's
going to try to win this game as well
yeah but he might even be trying to
he might be worsening his position in
the process look at this black rook it's
actually lacking squares you've got to
be really careful now as black yeah it's
nearly trapped that rook isn't it so
it's quite quite risky this play i mean
it's just inconsistent right he spent
what was it 15 moves just king back and
forth back and forth back and forth
doing nothing and then suddenly maybe
he's looking at ding's clock time maybe
he's realizing okay this is the moment
to go for it
um ding is down under four minutes
magnus almost at 15.
so 11 extra minutes on the clock maybe
he thinks magnus even if things go wrong
he's still pretty solid he can still
calculate his way out of trouble
and um
yeah i mean things are about to open up
maybe we can jump in to show why magnus
is playing for the win how he's playing
for the win it was all about pushing
this pawn forward the idea is to crack
open a line for the rooks but i don't
really know what he's doing for the
with those black rooks for example if
white takes his pawn it looks like the
black rook can come down and give a
check but it's just one check the white
king can step back and
suddenly you've lost a pawn and the
black king is a bit open for example
pawn takes pawn and white will recapture
two good bishops white's rook as well
are ready to swing across and attack the
black king
and look at the h pawn i mean this is uh
this is one of those cases where you see
you put the pawn on this square
you get it all the way up there it might
not seem obvious what it's doing but
then you know when as soon as the
position opens up it suffocates your
opponent's king and pawn takes pawn
looks like a a really good move to me
because
you've got the bishops you want to open
them up and he okay he can still play it
after the next move white's bishop
dropping back hitting the black rook and
if we see the black rook retreat then i
think ding would be very tempted to
capture this pawn as we just showed but
does the question is does magnus have
the time to play pawn takes pawn here
giving up some material but after bishop
takes rook
i mean there's no time to flick in a
check unfortunately but uh for example
if black captures this piece back we
could see a situation where black will
try and set up a blockade a barricade on
the dark squares white only has this
kind of poor blocked in light square
bishop no influence on the dark squares
but white does have an extra rook for
the black knight maybe at some point uh
we'll see the white rooks occupy this
open line and break through no magnus
doesn't go for this he retreats so we
might see this on the board white is
about to go one pawn up
pawn takes pawn and position opens up i
think in ding's favor
can magnus activate his rooks that is
the question can he find sufficient
counterplay against the white king i
don't see it i really don't see it as
just a check and that's it the king
steps back
nothing nothing left unless he tries to
bring his rook across and then bring the
other rook down to the second rank oh
but that's so risky so risky for example
let's just ignore everything white's
doing and
okay maybe the black rooks can come into
the game like this
but let's go back to the position
because this is the second time we've
seen this position now ding only has two
and a half minutes if he wants to win
he'll take this pawn if he wants to draw
he'll just drop his bishop back and
attack the black rook um two minutes
left on the clock for ding
14 minutes left for magnus and uh how is
ding in the when clocks runs down and
and it's a blitz chess
he's good at blitz but he does panic a
little bit more than magnus he doesn't
play as much online i don't think he's
as quick on the mouse over the board
blitz he's very very good yeah we've
seen him do well in the tour on uh in
blitz as well but magnus is maybe
another level okay so let's go back to
the players will he drop his bishop back
and go for the draw
or is he going to play politics pawn and
go for the win under two minutes i guess
the longer he thinks about it the more
likely he is to go for the jewish yeah
what do you think simon well he's gone
for a draw yeah
and i think the tournament situation i
mean a draw they both qualify it's it's
i mean okay i mean i think
david would have definitely gone for the
win there no matter what but i mean it
is kind of sensible as well with two
minutes yeah i would have gone for the
win and then lost
so
that's why ding is the world number two
yeah i mean it
it's a practical choice isn't it and i
think they'd be shaking hands soon but
in terms of the tournament situation it
makes sense uh to play it safe but you
can can he still so he can still go pawn
takes point
i thought it would be a draw
automatically now but this is his last
chart now it is there we go third time
we've seen that position it is a draw a
draw between world number one and world
the number two thing and
magnus and maybe